- I want to have dragons and dire wolves
and mammoths and a wall of
ice that's 700 feet tall.
A minute ago I don't like stories
or books that are too
familiar, too predictable,
that I feel like I read
a thousand times before.
Very few people get up in the morning
and say oh I'm evil,
what evil can I do today?
It's always said that
no is the sexiest word
you can say in Hollywood.
The more you say no
the more they want you.
- He's an American novelist, screenwriter,
and TV producter.
He's best known for his
series A Song of Ice and Fire
which was later turned
into HBO's Game of Thrones.
In 2005 Time Magazine called
him the American Tolkien.
He's George R. R. Martin
and here is my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
make sure to stick around
all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips and as always
as George is talking, if he says something
that really is meaningful to you,
that has a big impact on you,
please leave it in the comments below
so others can benefit from
the experience as well. Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- And I started actually
writing a science fiction novel
that had been an idea I'd
been playing with a long time,
a book called Avalon, and
I was working on Avalon
and it was coming pretty well
and suddenly the first chapter
of Game of Thrones came to me,
where they find the dire wolf pups.
- It's a freak.
- It's a dire wolf.
- I knew it wasn't part of
the science fiction novel I was writing.
This was clearly a fantasy, medieval,
had these wolves and this large family.
I'd been reading a lot
of historical fiction
and it might of been
in the back of my mind
but suddenly it all gelled
and I wrote that chapter
in like two or three days.
It just came to pour out of me.
- Lord Stark.
There are five pups, one for
each of the Stark children.
The dire wolf is an
extension of your house.
They were meant to have them.
- You will train them yourselves.
You will feed them yourselves
and if they die, you'll
bury them yourselves.
- When I did return to books,
I said to myself okay, I've
had many things optioned,
they never make them.
I've done pilots and TV
shows, tried to keep them
within budget and produced
well, they never make that.
I'm tired of playing that game.
I'm going to, you know,
I have a big imagination,
I have an epic story I want to tell.
I'm going to make it as
big as my imagination.
I'm going to have all the
castles and battles I want.
I'm going to have hundreds of characters
'cause the real world is complex
and I want my fictional
world to be complex too,
not as kind of simplified thing.
I want to have giant battles.
I want to have incredible castles
that each one is distinct from the other
that people will remember for all time.
I want to have dragons and dire wolves
and mammoths and a wall of
ice that's 700 feet tall.
I want something huge and epic
that could stand up there with Tolkien.
Ask yourself, what if no one
ever bought any of my work?
What if I'm never going to sell a book
or publish a book or a short story?
Are you going to continue to write?
And if the answer's
yes, because I have to,
then yeah, then you are a writer
and whether you'll sell
or not, I can't know
but if there's stories in
you that have to get out,
you want to put them down on the paper
whether you ever get the affirmation
of a contract or a book in your hand
or being on the bestseller list,
if you still have to tell your stories
then you're a writer.
If you can give it up,
then it probably would be
an act of sanity to learn
accounting or something like that.
I have tons of things I'd like to do
and life is short,
unfortunately, but I hope
it will be long enough for
me to do some of these.
I have known a few
writers who have retired.
I cannot imagine ever retiring.
Writing and being a writer is
too much a part of my identity
and too much a part of what I am.
I don't know what I would
do with all that time
if I did stop writing.
You know, play video games
or something like that.
Watch a lot more television.
It seems unlikely to me.
I've always told stories
whether I could make
my living from it or even
when I was a little kid
just making up stories for the other kids
in the neighborhood and I
think I'm going to continue
to do that until the end.
- Quite the little climber aren't you?
How old are you boy?
- 10.
The things I do for love.
(gasping)
- I mean not many shows or books
have the guts to kill a 10 year old.
(laughing)
Let alone after him catching
an incestuous relationship.
- That's true.
(laughing)
Probably more surprising in the book
where of course he's the
first viewpoint character.
You know, he's the viewpoint character
of the first chapter
and then we switch way
a couple of viewpoints
and then come back to him.
Since he was first I think
the assumption of most readers
is that he's going to be, you
know, the main guy through that
and then suddenly you think
he's dead or maybe he's dead.
But we find out more later.
But you know it's what I ...
We write what we want to read
and I, as I said a minute
ago, I don't like stories
or books that are too familiar,
that are too predictable,
that I feel like I read
a thousand times before.
So I want to keep you
on edge and surprise you
and make you think that no one is safe
and that was certainly the intent there.
And that scene has, I think,
gotten a lot of people
hooked on these books and said you know
I thought I was reading
just another fantasy
until I hit that scene and then I realized
that this was something
a little different.
So that moment has
worked very well for me.
- You are no knight.
You have forsaken every vow you ever took.
- So many vows.
They make you swear and swear.
Defend the king, obey the
king, obey your father,
protect the innocent, defend the weak.
And what if your father despises the king?
What if the king massacres the innocent?
It's too much.
No matter what you do, you're
forsaking one vow or another.
- I think the struggle
between good and evil
is central to fantasy
and indeed in some ways
central to most fiction.
It's certainly a worthy
subject for fiction.
But where I think I differ is I regard
the struggle between good and evil
as being waged within the
individual human heart.
It's not waged as fantasy would have it
where a character like
called the dark lord
gathers all the evil people together
and puts them in black clothing
and you know they're evil
'cause they're really ugly
and all the good people are handsome
and they wear white and they
meet on a big battlefield.
In the real world good and
evil are not that complex.
Very few people get up in the morning
and say oh I'm evil,
what evil can I do today?
I'm going to cover the world with darkness
and my legions of evil will rule all.
That's silly, you know.
The greatest monsters of
history, as we look back on them,
thought they were the heroes of the story.
You know, the villain is
the hero of the other side
as sometimes said.
That doesn't mean that
it's all morally relative.
That doesn't mean that all
things are equally good and evil.
I think there is good and
there is evil in the world
but you know, it's sometimes a struggle
to tell one from the other
and to make the right choices.
And all of us, we've always been attracted
to great characters, maybe
because that's what I see
when I look around the real world.
I read about it in history books
or the news or just people I meet.
I mean, all of us have it
within ourselves to be heroes.
All of us have it within
ourselves to be villains.
We've all done good things in our lives
and most of us have also
done selfish things,
cowardly things, things that we're
ashamed of in later years and to my mind
that's, I don't know, the
glory of the human race.
We're such wonderfully
contradictory, mixed up creatures
that are endlessly fascinating
to write about and read about.
David Benioff and Dan
Weiss are the show runners.
You know, I don't have any veto power.
I signed a pretty standard contract
where I gave them rights to adapt this
into a television series
and I got certain titles
and the agreement I'd
write one script a year
and a large dump truck full of money.
(laughing)
And they can do, you know,
they can have the aliens
come down next season.
They can turn the whole
cast into vampires.
And I'm powerless to stop them
but I don't think they will do that.
They love the books
and they seem committed
to telling my story in a different medium.
And I knew all that before I
signed any of the contracts.
I mean, when these books started hitting
the New York Times Bestseller List
which was as early as Clash of Kings,
I was approached by other
people who wanted to adapt them,
many for feature films and I
had meetings with those people
and you know, heard their plans.
How were they going to fit this
giant thing in a feature film?
Well, we're going to make
it all about Jon Snow.
We'll drop all these other characters
or we'll make it all about Dany
and we'll drop all these other characters.
They had various schemes
of how they would do it.
Or well, we'll just make the
first book up to this point
and then you know, we hope that the movie
will do well enough that
they'll order a second movie
and none of these really appealed to me.
So I said no, which is, it's always said
that no is the sexiest word
you could say in Hollywood.
The more you say no
the more they want you.
(laughing)
I guess that was true
'cause they kept coming
and eventually David and Dan came
and we had a wonderful meeting
that lasted like most of the day.
We met for lunch and we were talking
and getting animated about how we were
going to do the series over lunch
in a crowded restaurant in Los Angeles.
Little by little it emptied out
and pretty soon we were
the only people there,
you know, drinking our seventh
cup of coffee and iced tea
and still talking about it.
And then more hours passed
and we're still talking
and the restaurant
dinner crowd is coming in
and they're setting up for dinner.
I think we closed that
restaurant that night.
So it was one of those classic meetings
that you only get once in awhile
but I had a great feeling about them.
You know, if you're J. K. Rowling
you can go into a situation
where every studio
in Hollywood wants you and you can set
very stringent terms where
you get to approve everything.
But if you're not J. K. Rowling
and virtually nobody is J. K. Rowling
except for J. K. Rowling,
then you can't do that
and you have to find people that you trust
and put your faith in them
and in the understanding of the story.
I think I was a sophomore in high school
and I was kind of a nerdy kid, you know.
I wasn't one of the cool kids.
I wasn't good at sports.
I was good at, you know,
honor roll and stuff
but that doesn't cut any slack in school.
That just gets you more abuse.
(laughing)
But, sophomore year one
of my English teachers
was teaching Poe's Pit and the Pendulum
and he said, you know, this
story has a terrible ending.
If you remember that story,
the guy's in the pit,
the pendulum coming lower and lower
and then suddenly in the last paragraph,
trumpet sound and the pendulum
pulls up and he's saved.
The inquisition is in
the hands of its enemies
is the last thing and you know,
my English teacher said this is
a classic example of the Deus Ex Machina.
So our assignment was
to write a better ending
for the Pit and the Pendulum.
- [Man] Oh boy.
- So, I wrote an ending
where the rats came out
and ate the guy and they ate his cheeks
and they ate his toes
and they ate his face.
And the pendulum cut him in half
and he died horribly,
screaming in horrible pain.
I thought it was a much better ending
than the one that Edgar
Allen Poe came up with.
- It has a certain uplift to it, I feel.
- It does.
(laughing)
But what was the real boost for me
is the teacher liked it too and he had me
read it to the class and suddenly
all these kids who'd
never thought much of me
thought I was the
coolest kid in class man.
Wow, what a great ... (laughing)
What a great story.
The rats ate the guy.
They loved it and I said oh,
I got to do more of this writing stuff.
It really pays off.
When you're writing fantasy,
I've never obviously
been a prince, I've never been a king.
I've never murdered anyone.
I'd never been a dwarf.
I've never been an 11 year old girl.
So the question is how do
you write these characters?
Well, there's a certain amount of stuff
that you have to get by doing research.
You have to talk to people who actually
have had these experiences.
Like when Bran was crippled by his fall,
I had a couple correspondences
with readers of mine
who were paraplegic and
had no use of their legs
and you know described to
me some of the consequences,
some of the things I
might not have thought of
and made suggestions to me
of how better to write that
and I certainly took that
sort of stuff into account.
But the main thing is
empathy, is saying well okay,
how would I feel 'cause the
character is still a person.
There's a certain basis
of common humanity.
And that's true when writing about women
or writing about a dwarf or
writing about any of those.
You have to start with the basis,
they're more like me
than they are unlike me.
- [Man] Right.
- They have some special condition
that they have a different
set of genitals than I do
but it's still the same old story,
a fight for love and glory right?
- [Man] Right.
- We all want kind of the
same things out of life
and that humanity can motivate characters
and make them real and that's what I try
to remember at all times.
When you write, when I write anyway,
I wan to engage my readers' emotions
or my viewers' emotions.
You don't want, you know,
death is a big thing.
When we experience death in real life,
it effects us, you
know, when a spouse dies
or your parents die, your brother dies,
your dog gets run over or God forbid
one of your children
dies, rips your heart out.
It effects you emotionally.
If we're creating characters
that we really care about,
we should react in a
similar way when they die
in fiction or on television.
It shouldn't be oh okay,
that character's dead.
Let me go out and get a
sandwich during the commercial.
I mean, then you're not doing your job.
I want to grab hold of my readers
and make them cry and make them grieve
and make them laugh as
well and experience joy,
experience the worlds on the page
as if they were living them.
That's the dream of me at least
and I think of most writers.
- How did you decide on the name Hodor?
(laughing)
(clapping)
- That's not his real name,
that's just what they call him.
(laughing)
His real name is Walter.
If you were named Walter you might want
to be called Hodor too.
I don't know, you have to keep reading.
(struggling)
- Hold the door.
Hold the door.
(gasping)
(struggling)
Hold the door.
- Hey, what's the matter?
- [Girl] Hold the door.
- Hold the door.
Hold the door.
(sad music)
Hodor. Hodor. Hodor.
Hodor. Hodor. Hodor. Hodor.
Hodor. Hodor. Hodor. Hodor. Hodor. Hodor.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
TheBalls asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also want to know which rule was your
personal favorite and why.
What impact is it going to
have on your business or life?
Please leave it down in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tuan Nguyen.
Thank you so much for picking up 10 copies
of my book and leaving
that awesome picture
on the Amazon review.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- You have to read widely.
That's one thing that I try to hammer home
especially at things like
a comic book convention
or a science fiction convention
because the fans I've met
and this has been true for decades,
many of the fans I meet read a lot
but they read very narrowly.
They discover at a very early age
they like superhero
stories and then they read
nothing but superhero stories.
Or they like science
fiction and they read that.
That's fine and I like
superhero stories too
and I like science fiction and fantasy,
but I also read mystery novels.
I also read a lot of historical fiction.
I also read literary fiction and you know,
Raymond Chandler and F. Scott Fitzgerald
and William Goldman and Dennis Lehane
and people like that
are marvelous writers.
And the more you read the more you see
the techniques being used,
and what different people are
doing, the more you learn.
- Have you ever been influenced by
some of the crazy theories
your fans come up with
for mysteries in the books?
Have you ever changed
an aspect of your story
based on fan feedback?
I E if one of their theories
is better than what
you originally planned?
(laughing)
- No.
But I am concerned about that possibility
which is one of the reasons I don't
tend to read the fan boards.
I mean, when the first fan
board started occurring
and they started theorizing
and analyzing the books
in such detail and I'm going back now
to the mid 90s really, when
the first boards appeared.
Dragonstone coming out of
Australia that Peter Gibrand
I think was the first board I was aware of
and a couple others came up after that.
I was very flattered and I
did read all the theories
and then precisely this point occurred
where it says, you know,
what if they're guessing
the things that I haven't revealed yet?
What if they guess them correctly?
How does that effect me?
Do I then say oh my God
they figured it out already,
I better change it?
Or do I just ignore it and plow ahead?
And what if they come up with better ideas
than the ones I had, do I steal them?
And I didn't like any
of these possibilities
so I said it would be better for me
to try to keep my distance
and not go on these boards.
Somehow it was a futile
effort because people also
write me emails and people
come to public forums like this
and they come up to me at signings
and whisper their theories in my ear
and things like that.
(laughing)
So I am kind of aware of some
of the speculation out there
but I try to keep my distance from it
precisely because I don't
want to be impacted.
I mean, you know, it's
one of the drawbacks
of the whole internet
culture in this world
that you guys have created,
that something that previously
maybe one reader in
1,000 would have guessed,
but you still had the other
999 who would have no inkling
until you reveal it in a book.
Now, that one person in 1,000
puts it on an internet message board
and everybody sees it
and they say oh yeah,
yeah yeah that's right.
Now I see the clues.
And pretty soon half the readership
or at least the internet savvy portion
of your readership knows it.
But what do you do then?
Do you change it and
come up with something
goofy and outlandish that you haven't done
the foreshadowing for,
that you haven't laid
the foundation for just in
order to surprise people?
I mean, sure I could have
like aliens come down
and that would certainly surprise
the hell out of everybody.
No one is predicting that.
(laughing)
It would ruin the series.
So basically you can't let yourself
be influenced by this
stuff and I try not to.
I'm writing the Winds of Winter,
which is book six in the series
and I hope the next to last book.
The last book will be A Dream of Spring.
Once those are done,
then I can take a rest
and enjoy a few of the accolades
and the fruits of success
that have accumulated to me
and go back to writing something or other.
And I'll be a different person then
and the world will of changed
and I'll see what I feel like writing
in whatever year that happens to be.
I should be doing that right now.
You're interfering with me. (laughing)
I'm sure this book will be a year late
just because of you.